I'm just having an existential crisis I
just you seem to have those a lot I'm
just I'm not even gonna show the game
because I'm just running in circles and
making people used to doing world of
warcraft when I had nothing to do I was
waiting for a raid or I was waiting for
people to log on I wouldn't go out
I wouldn't farm I wouldn't do anything I
just run in circles like I don't have
anything to do it I know where to go so
I just it's like it's an analogy for my
life I just end up running around doing
nothing and panicking about all the
things that I do and complaining about
the problems that are happening in my
life could vomit it out I haven't even
eaten anything I've ate in something I
ate yet I did eat something but that's
not the point
you had it yeah it's not a congealed
evil that I holed up inside of me and I
vomit out in a black orb of nothingness
it's just I just can't do it I just have
I have these crisis moments where I was
like when problems surmount too high and
I just can't physically deal with them I
can't capable I have an incapable of
handling them so circles is all I do
okay buddy I don't know if it is man I
don't know if it is there's been a
whirlwind of a string oh my god I see
the space elevator people could see this
so big other people can't see it because
I go my god my monitors covering up my
webcam
[Applause]
[Laughter]
my big fancy 144 P 1440p Hertz monitor
is just 1440p Hertz Manos days I'm still
fifth in line I'm not going anywhere I'm
not going anywhere in life with this I
don't know man this elevator is touching
things that would be so cool to show but
I can't so much potential in my life and
yet I Eli squander it by never going the
full distance the extra mile I just
don't do it I can't do it no I have no
hope oh please just tell me it's gonna
be okay
mark it's gonna be fine bud you know I
don't even know how I have supplies but
no willpower
I can't just click just get some stuff
and just click some stuff it's ok if you
want a little insight everyday on the
tour we did was basically like this
[Laughter]
sitting in the backstage hanging out and
Mark would just be storming around
violent crisis of faith in himself it's
ok comes and goes oh God but it's really
coming and there's no one to go with
hey don't know it I guess maybe it's not
so bad after all it's all good cuz maybe
I'll just look at some memes that
usually helps people right
Oh button you know what my computer will
lag up even opening a Chrome browser
cuz there's only 32 gigs of RAM in this
I can't do it kid memes can't help it so
one thing memes can't fix me I'm about
to turn 30 exactly today exactly today's
three months away three months away I'll
be thirty years old now what happened I
squandered my life playing video games
okay get it out I'm fine I'm good I'm
good I'm good oh yeah it's all good it's
good it's good
all right I'm good sorry yes I'm good
I'm fine no it comes and goes
you just gotta wait for it to go it's
it's gone it's gone I'm good
[Music]